we've had some black supreme court
justices on before and how did how did
people like joe biden treat them during
their confirmation hearing because i
suspect
perhaps it might not be exactly the way
joe would have you think it was good
morning judge
welcome to the blinding lights
finding out what you mean when you say
that you would apply the natural law
philosophy to the constitution is in my
view
the single most important task of this
committee
senator biden was very focused on
natural law how did that go who knows i
have no idea what he was talking about
i just want to make sure we all know
what we're talking about here that you
and i know at least what we're talking
about here there's a fervent and
aggressive school of thought
that wishes
to see natural law further inform the
constitution
than it does now
argued against by the positivists
led by judge borg now again that may be
lost on all the people
you know and i know what we're talking
about i have to be perfectly honest with
you i s you sit there and you have no
idea
what they are talking about
all i know is that he was asking me
these questions about natural law
someone may apply it in a way
like more who leads him in a direction
that is quote liberal
you may apply it in a way that leads you
in a direction that's conservative
or you may
like many argue not applied at all
but it is a fundamental question that is
going to be almost impossible for
non-lawyers to grasp in an exchange
but you know and i know it is a big big
deal and in conclusion
one of the things you do in hearings
is you have to sit there and look
attentively
at people you know have no idea what
they're talking about
and it was fine i understood what he was
trying to do i didn't really appreciate
it
natural law was nothing more than a way
of tricking me
into talking about abortion this is a
case in which this leads
this dirt
was searched for by
staffers of members of this committee
was then leaked
to the media
and this committee
and this body
validated it
and displayed it
at prime time over our entire nation
this is a circus it's a national
disgrace
and from my standpoint
as a black american as far as i'm
concerned it is a high-tech lynching
for uppity blacks
who in any way deign to think for
themselves
we already have a mayor we don't need
any more big shots
okay so obviously that was clarence
thomas during his confirmation hearing
uh and he mainly he's going after mostly
democrats there obviously but very much
focused on joe biden actually uh and if
you want more on just joe biden's
history going after supreme court
nominees just google uh joe biden and
robert bork okay
so
it's not that joe biden is for black
people or democrats or for black people
there are four
people who behave they way they want
them to behave
nobody in america really except for
modern democrats progressives leftists
cares about your skin color nobody cares
they're just nobody is nobody cares it's
all they got left it's all they got left
so pandering joe biden congratulations
you you i guess in your myopic world
view look like mr tolerance and
non-racist or something because a black
woman is on the supreme court the person
i nominated will be put through a
painful and difficult confirmation
process
but i have to tell you
what judge jackson was put through
was well beyond that
there was verbal abuse the anger
the constant interruptions
the most vile baseless assertions and
accusations
in the face of it all
judge jackson showed the incredible
character and integrity she possesses
poise
[Music]
but just remember nobody really cared
and you tried to destroy uh one black
man who tried to get on the supreme
court about 30 some odd years ago by the
way you may remember we played this clip
last week nancy pelosi alcoholic
geriatric nancy pelosi she
said last week that she never thought
that clarence thomas should have been uh
put on the supreme court in the first
place so i guess she's racist
by
the modern thinking of the democrat
party
you